précédemment les terribles jeux pourris
continuent à semer la destruction sur la
terre mais l'enfant des jurons qui a
terminé l'entraînement de sonou revient
de grè vers le champ de bataille pour y
découvrir la puissance du 7 sens pendant
ce temps Sébastien continue à méditer au
chut des pour augmenter ENF son cosmosi
et peu importe qu'aucun DEES événements
ne se soit jamais passé dans l'épisode
précédent de toute façon c'était déjà
pas logique à la base
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
my god I got it
it's um
euh la tomber les fait trailer ça marche
pas alors fais un fondu l'ENV la scène
suivante pendant que je prends une tête
pens salut tout le monde aujourd'hui on
va aimer le cuir moi qui vous le dis
parce que le jeu dont je vais vous
parler m'a mis une tanée cuir tané
blague de merde vous avez compris non
sérieusement ce jeu dont je vais vous
parler aujourd'hui est un des jeux les
plus dur du monde ce jeu n'est pas
amusant c'est c'est pas marrant c'est
c'est la logique de ce jeu m'échappe
complètement enfin je veux dire autant
sur tortue ninja tu avais le côté encore
purement nostalgie ça peut se comprendre
mais là pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'on
irait volontairement se faire du mal
là-dessus ça n'a aucun sens bon je vais
aller chercher il est la cave
[Musique]
waouh c'est pratique la technique
Duchat allez nous y voilà c'est parti
pour Dragon slir alors dragon slir sur
Nintendo ce jeu fait clairement partie
des jeux les plus connus du net à cause
de sa difficulté qui est complètement
délirante mais à la base dragonir c'est
un très vieux jeu sorti sur arcade en 83
sous la forme d'un dessin animé
interactif où on devait cliquer au bon
moment sur la bonne touche pour faire
avancer l'histoire et oui c'est dragon
qui a inventé le principe du QTE qu'on
retrouve maintenant dans énormément de
jeux donc évidemment ce jeu sur arcade
n'a pu être accessible en console de
salon qu'après l'invention du support CD
sur la megéga CD la 3D ou la Philip CDI
et déjà à ce moment-là le jeu en dessin
animé donc le vrai dragon slir était
déjà une bonne purge ah oui parce
qu'atention là on parle pas dans ce jeu
de qite version moderne où tu as 2
minutes pour réagir et on te dit sur
quel bouton appuyer
non parce que c'est sûr que si pour vous
les QTE c'est des trucs ultra simples
qu'on croise dans les Call of Duty ou
autre FPS du genre vous risquez d'être
surpris non non le QTE version dragon
LIR on te dit absolument pas sur quel
bouton appuyer ni quand faut appuyer
c'est ça qui est magique c'est à toi de
deviner quelle touche va selon toi
servir et surtout à quel diième de
seconde il faut appuyer dessus
évidemment c'est absolument impossible à
deviner à moins de d'essayer de
absolument toutes les combinaisons de
touches à tous les
instants en plus mais c'est absolument
pas logique genre là par exemple le trou
apparaitt devant moi alors moi
j'aiappuyais sur arrière pour reculer
mais en fait non il fallait appuyer deux
fois sur droite ou là c'est pareil tu as
un machin qui clignote en haut tu crois
qu'il faut appuyer sur ha donc non c'est
pas ça mais put mais c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi ce jeu en plus je le
redis mais la fenêtre de tir pour
appuyer est minuscule regardez ça je je
vous montre ce que ça donne je mets
l'écran en rouge sur le lapse de temps
sur lequel il faut
[Musique]
appuyer j'ai calculé ça fait
0,4
secondes ce jeu a été conçu pour une
race de super en je crois je veux dire
si tu appuies avant la fenêtre de tir tu
meurs si tu appuies après tu meurs si tu
appuies au bon moment mais tu tromes de
bouton tu meurs évidemment si tu spames
ta manette c'est si tu appuies deux fois
au lieu d'une tu meurs c'est
insupportable sans déconner tu passes
ton temps à crever sans savoir pourquoi
mais tuimagine ça le fric de fou qu'il
faudrait dépenser pour avancer sur une
bord d'arcade en vrai alors les enfants
vous m'aviez bien dit que vous aimiez le
camping ça tombe bien on va vivre sous
une tente à partir de maintenant et oui
papa a tout perdu en dragon
bref voilà ça c'est le vrai dragon slir
et l'adaptation sur support CD de la
version arcade sortie 10 ans plus tôt
mais évidemment ils ont pas attendu les
support céd pour faire les portages de
ce jeu on a aussi eu droit à des
adaptations de ce jeu en plateforme et
on va commencer par la fin avec Dragon
slir sorti sur SuperNes
[Musique]
en2 alors dragon slir sur SuperNes alors
au début ça commence plutôt
tranquillement dès le niveau 1 bon la
maniabilité est pas sensationnelle les
graphismes sont pas vraiment moches bon
ça casse pas trois pates un connard mais
bon on a déjà vu pire les saut sont
vraiment pourris ça c'est sûr bon on
mais on avance sans trop galérer on peut
taper à l'épée on peut jeter des armes à
distance on peut aussi casser des objets
qui lâcheront des items et ça tombe
plutôt bien puisque dans les premiers
niveaux du jeu on croise de l'énergie
absolument partout donc bon ben ça va
pas l'air bien dur tout ça et finalement
on se dit on commence à se dire que bon
ça sera pas si
mal et oui ne vous fiez pas aux
premières impressions de ce jeu parce
que Dragon slir fait partie des jeux qui
utilisent la technique dite de la
sucette c'est-à-dire on te met des
premiers niveau veau sympa pour mieux
t'attirer dans la camionnette blanche
pour que tu achètes le jeu et après on
sachez que cette technique n'est
employée que par deux types de personnes
les développeur de mauvais jeux vidéo et
les vieux pervers et que dans les deux
cas tu as mal au cul à la fin en fait
déjà passer les quatre premiers niveaux
tous les items qui redonnit de la vie
disparaissent donc on se retrouve à
perdre de la vie en permanence sans
jamais pouvoir la regagner à ça en plus
faut rajouter que les ennemis
réapparaissent absolument sans aucune
interruption notamment ces [ __ ] de
dragon vert là ils peuvent apparaître
n'importe où je veux dire même dans le
sol dans l'angle mort de ton épée là où
tu pourras jamais les toucher
franchement je suis mort un nombre juste
hallucinant de fois parce que de ces
[ __ ] de dragons de merde là est
apparu dans le sol et m'a touché sans
que je puisse rien faire et et le le
pire c'est qu'il te lâche pas je veux
dire dans tous les jeux du monde quand
un monstre sort de l'écran il disparaît
mais là non là il continue à te suivre
et à te harceler en permanence comme un
conseiller pour l'emploi quoi écoute il
y a un niveau dans ce jeu après y avoir
joué j'étais tellement énervé que j'ai
dû aller mater trois épisode de La
petite maison dans la prairie pour pas
devenir psychopathe mais en fait ça m'a
énervé encore plus donc finalement c'est
con c'était dans le dans le niveau je
dans le niveau je sais plus combien
écoute on va l'appeler le niveau
pourquoi le niveau parce que à la fin
quand il joue ben tu es comme
ça donc ce niveau commence par une bonne
corde qu'on peut pas attraper h la bonne
corde qu'on peut pas attraper
l'indispensable ingrédient d'un jeu de
merde ah [ __ ] si tu veux faire un jeu
chiant il faut forcément qu'il ait
quelque part une corde qu'on peut pas
attraper non mais non mais regardez ça
j'ai le corps entièrement pardessus la
corde j'appuie sur le bouton haut comme
un tar pour la choper mais il y a rien à
faire ça ça veut pas allez
attrapep
allez ah oui parce que un truc que j'ai
pas dit aussi vous pouvez peut-être vous
demander pourquoi je pars pas par la
droite directement et ben c'est parce
qu'en fait les niveaux ont tous une
fausse sortie qui te ramène un niveau en
arrière ah ça aussi quand tu connais pas
c'est la bonne surprise tu te casses le
cul à finir un niveau pour te rendre
compte qu'en fait non seulement tu
avances pas mais en plus tu recules et
vous savez le pire c'est que je suis sûr
que quand ils ont fait ça les mecs ils
se sont dit que que c'était amusant quoi
je suis sûr qu'ils se sont dit allez on
va faire ça ça ça va être rigolo les
gens ils vont reculer de niveau ou alors
ils vont aller vers un niveau qui sert à
rien ça va être ça va être marrant ça va
être une surprise
amusante à qui tu parles là je sais pas
j'ai eu envie de faire ça soudainement
sans aucune
raison donc voilà la corde c'était
euh c'était l'étape facile ouais ouais
juste après la corde alors que tu viens
bien de te faire chier à passer 20
minutes pour comprendre comment
l'attraper direct un notre truc donc
maintenant c'est une enclume qu'il faut
pousser pour la la faire tomber en
dessous dans le fourneau qui te tue en
un coup et t'en servir comme plateforme
pour pouvoir passer le
piège voilà trop loin on recommence le
niveau ben oui obligé vu que l'enclume
ne réapparaît pas et c'est le seul
chemin pour finir le niveau donc c'est
où tu réussis ou tu te suicides pour
pouvoiréessayer
doucement doucement ta mère ah [ __ ]
tout ça pour aller chercher une
princesse à la con qui va encore
t'embrasser sur la joue à la fin du jeu
allez doucement voilà
voilà c'est bon allez [ __ ] non ne me
fais pas le coup de
[ __ ] le mot de passe pas utiliser un mot
de passe maintenant franchement ça sera
abusé
ok A B C D
1 2 3 qu
4 qu'est-ce que attends c'est ça les
[ __ ] attends ça veut dire qu'il faut
déplacer les boules une par une sous
l'eau pour les mettre dans les trou qui
sont en bas pour pouvoir constituer le
mot de passe à qu lettres mais c'est
ultra relou en fait je veux dire dans la
version américaine tu avais aussi un
petit jeu un petit jeu comme ça mais
c'était vite fait non non pas par là pas
par là
ah j'ai bloqué ma boule j'ai perdu à
l'écran des mot de passe ah
non je veux juste rentrer un mot de
passe pourquoi ils ont fait un truc
aussi chiant je mets attends et là je
viens de mourir je viens de mourir dans
l'écran des mot de passe c'est une
blague ce truc mais c'est absolument le
pire système de mot de passe que j'ai
jamais vu dans tous les jeux auxquels
j'ai joué dans toute ma vie et j'ai
encore bloqué ma boule
[ __ ] je peux plus entrer les mot de
passe parce que ma boule est bloquée moi
aussi je perds la boule tu te crois
drôle c'est ça tu te crois drôle non
mais un mot de passe ça devrait être
simple à rentrer je veux juste rentrer
un [ __ ] de mot de passe pas jouer à
interville ce jeu a été fait par des
guignol ils sont fous ils sont
complètement fous Mme le système de pass
a été fait par des
fou je suis fou bonjour à tous je vous
présente la personne qui va développer
dragon lair sur
SuperNes c'était le moins cher et puis
en plus mais il y a un mode Expert hein
le mode Expert expert je suis un expert
parce que là je jouais en facile en fond
de giron il est temps tu affronter ton
ennemi et tu m'en fou cassez-vous ça va
pas la peine de gueuler c'est bon quoi
et puis vous savez quoi j'en ai plus
rien à [ __ ] alors je voulais pas le
faire mais on va faire le jeu sur NES
sur NES et vous savez quoi puis que de
toute façon il y a plus aucune logique
dans cette vidéo mais regardez le
jeunesse je le sors de mon cul
voilà bon essayons de redevenir calme
alors dragon slar sur NES ce jeu il est
très connu sur Internet parce qu'il est
mondialement réputé pour sa pourritud d'
extrême il est sorti en 90 aux
États-Unis et en 92 en France et si je
fais la précision c'est parce qu'en fait
les deux versions ne sont pas les mêmes
on a légèrement eu plus de chance en
Europe puis qu'en fait la version P de
dragon slir est légèrement mieux mux que
la version américaine alors pour
plusieurs raisons c'est que déjà il y a
eu plusieurs petits changements comme
par exemple des boss qu'on retrouve dans
la version Europe alors qu'ils sont pas
dans la version aux États-Unis mais bon
le plus gros changement c'est surtout
que la version européenne est plus
rapide ce qui est paradoxal he vu que
d'habitude c'est l'inverse mais bon
soyons honnête hein de toute façon dans
les de cas ce jeu est simplement pas
finissable je veux dire j'appelle pas ce
jeu très difficile parce que si on parle
de truc très difficile escala de
l'Himalaya c'est très difficile devenir
astronaute c'est très difficile savoir
chanter c'est très difficile mais là ce
jeu c'est comme si quelqu'un vous disait
esquive la balle ou je crois pas sans
aucune hésitation je vous affirme que
tortue ninja sur NES c'est mon petit
poney à côté de dragon slir sans
déconner c'est je veux dire tortue ninja
sur NES ça m'avait déjà hyper traumatisé
quand j'étais mom mais j'aurais eu
dragon slir sur NES mais mais mais je
sais je sais pas à quoi ma vie
ressemblerait aujourd'hui
quoi chérie je suis rentréouc mon
comment les enfants
ah que ma vie est belle depuis que j'ai
arrêté les jeux
vidéos ça serait horrible donc le jeu
commence sur le pont Levie du château on
a déjà un large aperçu de la galère qui
nous attend alors déjà la première chose
à dire vous voyez ça hein c'est une
barre d'énergie et bien ne sert
quasiment à rien vu que la plupart des
trucs vous tuent en un coup et et ça il
y a vraiment aucune logique je veux dire
bon qu'une boule de feu de dragon te tue
en un coup à la limite je peux
comprendre mais pourquoi est-ce que
toucher une porte te tue aussi en un
coup non mais c'est c'est une porte
enfin mais je sais pas une porte même à
l'intérieur du donjon c'est aussi
complètement in sensé une chauve-souris
presque pas de dégâts bon ok pourquoi
pas un petit caillou minuscule lancé par
un prisonnier Mor en un coup mais enfin
mais sérieux un méga sorcier malifique
qui se promène en volant et qui fait
changer la musique du jeu pour te dire à
quel point il est dangereux il te touche
et t'enlève deux pixels de vie et
derrière la petite araignée qui pend du
plafond et te one shot non mais c'est
quoi cette logique de merde enfin mais
c'est juste stup o est-ce que les mecs
qui ont fait ce jeu ont trouvé ça c'est
marrant on inverse la logique des
ennemis oh et là l'araignée elle est
plus forte que l' la sorcier parce que
elle te tue un coup quoi pourquoi vous
me regardez comme ça je fais un gâteau
pour revenir au niveau 1 donc il faut
passer le dragon en lançant des couteaux
depuis un pixel bien précis en se
baissant assez vite pour pas prendre la
boule de feu et pour pas que le dragon
redescende dans son trou alors c'est
chiant certes mais une fois qu'on a la
technique c'est pas hyper compliqué
finalement en fait ce passage ben c'est
le seul passage du jeu que tu peux
passer du premier coup quand tu le
maîtrises bien parce que tout le reste
même en connaissant à fond mais c'est
tellement du pixel près que tu ne peux
pas réussir les serpents par exemple ils
apparaissent à des endroits que rien
n'indique il y a pas de petite fissure
dans le mur ou quoi non non il te
balancec un truc qui évidemment tu tu en
un coup et si tu t'arrêtes un pixel trop
tard tu meurs et tu ne peux rien faire
tu vois la mort arrivée tu tu sais que
tu veux crever mais tu ne peux rien
faire parce que dans ce jeu tu ne peux
pas rattraper une erreur les mouvements
de ton perso sont beaucoup trop lents
pour tourner tu mets presque une seconde
entière mais dans un jeu qui demande de
réagir au 10è de secondes c'est c'est
affreusement et ce qui est terrible
c'est que c'est pareil dans tous les
niveaux prends le pont le vie par
exemple dans le niveau 1 si tu fais
demi-tour dessus le machin s'effondre et
tu crèves impossible de se retourner
vous trouvez ça chiant alors maintenant
imaginez un niveau entier comme ça si tu
t'arrêtes tu meurs parce que dans ce jeu
ça existe mais vous imaginez la version
américaine du jeu qui est encore plus
lente mais tu deviens taré quoi enfin
bon de toute façon tout dans ce jeu a
été calculé pour te faire chier les
trous par exemple je sais pas ENF est-ce
que quelqu'un peut m'expliquer comment
c'est possible de tomber dans ce trou je
sais pas le trou fait la largeur de la
main du héros [ __ ] mais regarde j'ai
les genoux d'un côté et les mains de
l'autre merde à la fin ah mais c'est
vrai enfin mais pourquoi chaque fois
qu'il faut sauver une princesse ils
envoient le roi des trous du cul pour
faire la mission bon donc à la fin du
niveau 2 on a un boss relativement
tranquille qui ensuite nous amène vers
ma partie préférée
l'ascenseur alors c'est pas un niveau il
y a aucune difficulté par particulière
il y a pas d'ennemi il y a juste bon
quelques cailloux qui tombent du ciel et
c'est tout alors pourquoi j'en parle ben
en fait c'est parce que ce niveau est
juste là pour t'emmerder ça c'est
l'esprit typique de ce jeu je veux dire
dans ce niveau l'ascenseur va tomber et
s'arrêter devant des plateformes chaque
plateforme correspond à un niveau mais
absolument rien n'indique quelle
plateforme tu dois prendre hein au
passage d'ailleurs noter que la hitbox
des plateformes est totalement
dépendante du mouvement de l'ascenseur
ça veut dire que si tu sautes un S
de seconde trop tard alors que tu tombes
parfaitement sur la planche tu traverses
et tu meurs comme une merde concernant
l'ordre des plateformes c'est simple si
tu prends la plateforme numéro 1 tu
ressors à l'entrée du niveau 2 que tu
viens juste de faire et donc tu dois
tout te retaper pour aller au niveau 3
tu prends la deuxième plateforme si tu
prends la trème plateforme tu rentres
dans une sal à part où tu es bloqué par
de port pour accéder au niveau 4 c'est
aussi la trème plateforme et qui se
débloque après le niveau précédent et
enfin pour accéder au niveau 5 il s'agit
évidemment de la première plateforme qui
2 minutes avant était en fait le niveau
[Musique]
vous l'aurez peut-être noté mais je n'ai
pas parlé de la 4ème plateforme quand tu
rentres dedans tu te retrouves bloqué
dans une salle inutile avec un boss
immortel et tu ne peux pas te barrer vu
qu'à chaque fois tu réapparais dedans
dès que tu meurs he le seul moyen de
sortir c'est de galérer comme un con
pour ramasser ce J qui correspond au
Gold que le monstre lézard te pique
quand il te touche dans les niveaux
précédents pour résumer l'ascenseur il
descend quand il est tout en bas il est
bloqué parce qu'évidemment il remonte
plus et donc tu es condamné à perd
toutes tes vides dans cette salle parce
qu'évidemment le truc à ramasser pour
sortir il est collé au boss qui te but
en un coup et il cliote aussi c'est plus
marrant évidemment évidemment et si tu
arrives quand même à le ramasser bravo
tu as gagné des points pour le high
score qui disparaîtra dès que tu
éteindras la
console ah je suis qu'à la fin du deuxè
niveau je redeviens déjà fou et comme il
y a trop de truc pourris que je peux pas
tous vous les montrer avvez quoi mais je
vais vous le chanter
recette pour jeux pourris un courant
d'air qui déconne une lampe qui
t'abandonne des plateforme pourri
rajouter une
chau-souris je vais en mettre deux un
boss presque impossible une plateforme
inaccessible ce mec est un abruti tu
viens de perdre une vie non je viens
d'en perdre trois ah bon je CIS
expérience pathétique ce jeu fait par
des sadiques demain oui je l'abandonne
sur la route de
Narbonne
dans les PO
[Musique]